akin to this video playing at them Kuna
[ __ ] from Austria let's see what can I
do here
play something else d6 area sort of a
modern defense and always Shriya that
that's very inspiring but okay
certainly a playable move Knight f6 get
into the pills probably yeah here I can
take only form this is well known
actually now he's got h3 end which
cannot really help him a lot let's do
that it's not even taking their who what
now it gets weird I can't take both look
good let's take here I have c5 here is
one way to to counter that c5
see finally you can maybe take try to
keep that probably not I mean what he
has achieved with all this is I really
spent time for this for this stuff
Quincy 7 maybe he's got 94 94 Bishop f5
ok I'm spending too much time for all
this probably I cannot refute it
completely anyway it's not any any great
but but still something that shouldn't
shouldn't do so anything for one I get
c5 back here of course but he has a
decent position ok
what's bra ah well no b5 before maybe
it's not like I'm better but I don't see
why I should take it wrong
okay c8 Luke f CH don't know maybe this
one making maybe I can try to play 9075
C for something something along these
lines
[Music]
[Music]
I'm 95 you might play Bishop f4 hmm okay
okay Quincy fine
it's nothing terrible
[Music]
of course yeah of course he he this guy
just wants to trade off the whole board
and make a draw but it is some not going
to happen so easily I will continue here
hmm maybe I can get the a pawn he played
it in a way that day five has become a
weakness
[Music]
okay I take take everything off here
it's probably very drawn she's still but
probably not much that I can do you will
always have the counter play against be
70 M what first you're doing nothing
then you see a tactic well that's that's
not fair okay
fannia the D takes the I really cannot
play so I must take on one g7 and Queen
d6 he has Queen e8 with this after sis
those threats iam on D 1 and H 2 what he
can he can defend it funny of course I
can just take him
[Music]
they are not much going on maybe your
overlooks Bishop takes g2 always need to
be optimistic
position is of course very dry
[Music]
[Music]
he wants to go to g5 now probably I
should just just accept the draw him
Jack it's very difficult to imagine how
wide should lose this Jack but okay I've
seen seen strange things happening time
warning that one down on time which is a
bit worrisome check
[Music]
Joe this is what's not helping okay this
is really a total draupadi Gras
Arthur and I managed to make fifty Lucia
this was very boring this should be six
what to show come Jim but it's really
just sit wrong it's strange I mean this
opening was really total rubbish to be
honest maybe I should take the bishop
and this is better I don't know maybe I
should just take the bishop and then
just be a pawn up just it just looked
very very weird for white now this is
just better
I did not take the bishop I was thinking
that this is this never can be any good
but he probably gets it back on a form
there is an well-known line like this
but there there instead of h3y his
castle and if that is not very great so
I thought this must be good but it
really isn't that is not much going on
here
this is just a probably equal position
yeah not very exciting this game thanks
for watching